Jon Hamm of course gave us madmen he's
among a group of a listers who came
together on Saturday online poker
tournament I tuned in and I go late jon
Hamm's already out I think he was the
second guy out and then he bought back
in it's all in for America's charity to
raise money for feeding America and
thought that they did a wonderful job
with that are you are you any good at
poker John apparently you were being
generous were you trying to be generous
by buying back in so you could play I
was I can't remember where I left out as
I stand on but it was one of those deals
where you're like oh well here we are
whoops and you know it's it's a
testament to the guys that actually
played a game for a living that can that
can sit there for hours and Kevin Pollak
actually ended up I think coming in
second and I ended up watching the rest
of the tournament it was pretty cool but
I was like Pollak you're just way more
patient than I am because I just I want
the action what can't you act like a
good poker player yeah when when
somebody writes it in this group that I
get all the cool car Oh like Matt Damon
Matt Damon and rounders exactly when he
you know until he writes down that he
knows all the cards even yeah of course
I would be way might be way better at it
who else was at the table with you that
you found to be tough competition
because I have my table I had well I had
a college and for certain boys I had an
indie Milonakis I had tried everything
that I that I knew that I really knew
very well like so Silverman's playing in
it then and Matt we're both playing I
know both those guys but I didn't really
have anybody that I knew knew at my
tables and then everyone go under like
soon so I couldn't quite figure out
these two leaders but so oh I think I
had the Jay
Kimmel's Conceicao also there so what's
Tom Brady involved
you see if some good company all the all
the all the good guides busted out early
but I'm saying who's your best friend in
Hollywood question I think you wouldn't
know him but I met him actually at a
Super Bowl or something but my friend my
best friend is this guy goes by the name
of tall Jonah because in 6:10 he
actually was literally down the block
from me and we've been buds like 1992
when I came out here on spring break
from the University very and visited
some friends but but you don't hang with
do you hang with other like I don't hang
with other sports casters do you hang
with other actors not really it's like
my normal like people that I know you
know one of those great what is the
scene at home
what's the button do you have a man cave
and we long I got my office is kind of
where I spend the majority of my hours
know which I'm in right now my waking
hours in my house and I have pictures of
my old dog I've got my various and
sundry awards I've got my dream and I
had that collected over the years which
is a tribute to Stan Musial which is the
base that looks lined by him in one of
those bats no son yeah I've got my life
kind of you know my collected pictures
and memorabilia and baseballs and things
like that that I have that Pat over the
years so that's pretty much my that's
why essentially in my no joke it's
actually now
/ to go with about 18 hours Nick in
there I might get mad at me but I'm full
disclosure here I got all of the DVDs
for madmen somebody sent it in and the
reason why she sent it in is because
I've never watched an episode of Mad Men
mm-hmm are you mad you sir are you a mad
man at me not watching Mad Men you're a
busy guy you got stuff doing I'll be
honest with you I only watched about 70%
of the stuff okay that's fair and that's
that's fair but I you know you get it at
some point I've never watched The
Sopranos
I didn't watch Game of Thrones I waited
five years to watch The Wire I waited 10
years to watch Breaking Bad I think I'm
getting ready for Mad Men I think you're
ready it took me five years for the wire
I was bit very late for that one I was I
was losing due time with The Sopranos
and Breaking Bad but there's stuff that
I that's what it goes there's too much
TV this is what's happening now there's
too much give me the episode of Mad Men
that you say if I if you're only gonna
watch one for God's sakes watch this
episode well it's hard because you know
the show is so established on character
building and you have to know the
character so some of the later episodes
that are really dependent on that are
are you know that's that's the bigger
thing is that it's all of you if you've
sat with these guys so while these
things have a little more residents but
if I were to say one episode of the show
there's an episode in season 4 actually
the whole season four is pretty great
but season four called the suitcase
which is a kind of a little bottle
episode with Don and Peggy where they
get like locked in trying to figure out
an ad campaign for Samsonite the whole
thing
it just reminds me of dumb and Dumberer
everything I said but it's it's a really
good episode and a lot of things happen
with those especially those two
characters and it's look for my money
that's my favorite episode of the show
now my guy said there's a lot of
drinking in that episode what what is
the actual beverage that they give you
to drink weak diluted tea because that
looks the most like whiskey yeah you
know they make iced tea and then they
just pour it into your glass and so
you're just caffeinated the whole day
how difficult is it to act drunk way
easier than actually being there's no I
think I think somebody I said I don't
know who it was Dean Martin or something
back in the day but somebody said the
the the best the best rule for acting
drunk is that every every drunk person
doesn't want to look like they're drunk
right so they every every person that's
actually drunk thinks they're not but
think about it
he's Jon Hamm he starred in madman he
wanted a couple of Golden Globes I
believe for that and also they took part
in a charity poker event all in for
America's charity to raise money his
online poker tournament for feeding
America a couple of things here Top Gun
that is that done and what's your role
in Top Gun that is done we're finished
we finishing that last dot you know why
maybe it's coming out it was meant to
come out this summer but now we are in
well the upside down so that's not
happening
it's going to come out I think Christmas
that we moved it I play
characters call sign is cyclone play Tom
Cruise's superior officer who believe it
or not Tom's got some problems with
authority never doesn't to play by the
rule he didn't want to play by the rules
when the original came out he was
writing sexist body can't cash his name
is nick name is maverick what do you
expect him to be he's not going to be
compliant it's big he's maverick also is
there a cheesy line that will take out
of Top Gun there might be I don't really
have a good quotable one that I can
think of so like a need for speed and
things like that I'm sure that there is
Chris McQuarrie collate the script and
they were all very very aware and
cognizant kind of the legacy of Top Gun
so I'm pleased as punch with a I've seen
of it it's so good and and they look
obviously the originals in 1986 the
technology now of cameras and HD and
take whatever technology is also so much
better and just just the flying sequence
of alone are oh I also wanted to
compliment you on playing Larry David on
Curb Your Enthusiasm
I like did you ever think that I would
you know somebody would compliment you
on him by the way the way you played
Larry David was great
it's not a long list it let me see De
Niro do that hey Larry David we've seen
no i-i've known Larry for some time
Larry Larry and I worked together a
couple years back on him we called clear
history which is shot in Boston and we
got to know each other because he found
out I played golf and if you know Larry
Oh
and so we were sitting in Boston for a
month and a half shooting this movie and
he's got a bunch of Kermes there that he
loves playing golf with and I got hurt
those guys so I basically got beat by
Larry David critical for a month month
and a half and winning lives hundreds of
dollars on the golf course so it was
pretty fun yeah that episode was great
it's great to check in with you John I'm
glad you're doing well and keep in touch
we appreciate you joining us Dan I mean
it's you know I literally watched the
1982 World Series last night because
that's what was on and we're in a world
of retro sports it feels like I should
fire up my old Nintendo gaming system or
play some RBI Baseball or some tech
mobile I like but it it's here we are
it's the strangest thing but obviously
it's all done for the right reasons and
we're doing you know we're doing this
this thing is just stay healthy and stay
safe
ya know man it's pretty funky to have a
summer without sports I know and imagine
having a job where three hours a day
you're supposed to be talking about it
but you know that's where we appreciate
people like you coming in and filling in
some time Dan that's why I'm here
I'm gonna get around to Mad Men John I
promise I will
[Laughter]
Maggie John at John Hale madman